tout d'abord direction le zoo de Beauval
la nouvelle volière du parc la plus
grande d'Europe a ouvert le 15 avril
dernier et c'est déjà un succès puisque
le parc enregistre son meilleur mois
d'avril depuis sa création on peut venir
y admirer 400 oiseaux sud-américains et
une trentaine de mammifères le tout en
déambulant sur des passerelles suspendus
dans près de deux hectares Clémence
d'OSC et Léa Turquie l'ont visité pour
vous
[Musique]
deux hectares de superficie un filet à
30 mètres de hauteur 400 oiseaux et une
trentaine de mammifères oui nous sommes
bel et bien à la volière sud-américaine
au ZooParc de Beauval c'est la nouveauté
de cette saison 2023 elle a ouvert il y
a à peine une semaine et demi et pour
l'instant quelques oiseaux commencent à
s'acclimater nous sommes en hauteur pour
leur permettre de vivre tranquillement
une centaine d'oiseaux devraient arriver
dans les jours à venir donc ça va être
un travail qui va être fait en amont on
va simplement leur proposer des volets
qui s'appellent des volières de prélâché
pour qu'ils puissent voir
l'environnement avant c'est-à-dire
comprendre que au niveau du filet on
s'arrête et dès qu'ils ont compris on
peut les lâcher dans des volières avec
des superficie aussi grande que ce qu'on
a là aujourd'hui
[Musique]
la visite se fait de façon ludique sur
ses ponts de singes en hauteur ça permet
aux visiteurs de voir les oiseaux passés
également de pouvoir observer les singes
qui parfois traversent sur les cordes
pour l'instant tout le monde est conquis
les enfants comme les parents c'est
formidable il y a énormément d'animaux
et je pense qu'on va faire le tour avec
les enfants il y a ma fille qui est ici
et je pense qu'elle va adorer ça pour
l'instant on va pas beaucoup d'oiseaux
voler mais sinon c'est sympa c'est
agréable de se promener toute la cascade
tout ça c'est agréable je pense que
c'est pas mal faut attendre encore
quelques années que on voit encore de la
végétation à pousser quelques animaux
aussi prennent leur place c'est bien
c'est super de voir tous ces animaux
comme ça les oiseaux la place de bouger
c'est bien les singes sont marrants vous
êtes content de devenir les filles
les oiseaux qu'on voit en bas ne sont
pas des flamants roses ce sont des
flamants de Cuba il y a également des
ibis des cigognes de maguary et quelques
vautours se sont en tout une bonne
trentaine d'espèces d'oiseaux différents
qui cohabitent ensemble ici une variété
une diversité qui se veut un hommage à
la fondatrice du zoo de Beauval
Françoise de l'or maman était passionnée
d'oiseaux c'est ainsi qu'elle a ouvert
un petit parc d'oiseau en 1980 j'espère
qu'elle est fier de cet espace que nous
avons réalisé n'a pas eu l'occasion de
voir les plans mais je suis certain que
doué la volière a ouvert depuis
maintenant une semaine et demie deux
semaines quels sont les premiers retours
est-ce que vous voyez une hausse de la
fréquentation nous devrions atteindre va
dépasser 300 000 visiteurs sur le mois
d'avril ce qui est exceptionnel ce début
de saison des mars sous les chapeaux de
roues les fourmiliers mais également des
coéquipiers vont rejoindre les
mammifères et une centaine d'oiseaux
supplémentaires arriveront d'ici l'été
prochain